[Müzik]
Herkese merhabalar
hoş geldiniz
Ben de biraz huzursuz bacak sendromu var
o yüzden bolca gezeceğim alanımı da
kısıtladılar kırmızının dışına
çıkamıyorum
2008 yılında ilk defa Gazi
Üniversitesi'ne geldim Bu da benim
aslında
bağlayacağım ev yaşantımla birazcık
alakalıydı Çünkü Gazi mahallesinde
oturuyordum Buraya çok yakın bir yerde
Bu seçeneğimi üniversite seçimi yaparken
de önceliğim oldu Gazi Üniversitesi Gazi
Üniversitesi'ne girdikten sonra
seçimlerim birazcık değişti evdeki
ihtiyaçlarım da birazcık değişti Bugün
birazcık
insanların ihtiyaçlarından gelecekteki
ihtiyaçlardan
nereye gidiyoruz birazcık onlardan
bahsedeceğiz bizim tarafımızda neler
oluyor Onları göreceğiz geçmişten beri
insanlar hep evlerinde bir şeyler
aradılar Hala da aynı şeyler arıyoruz
birazcık huzur arıyoruz birazcık Konfor
arıyoruz Güven arıyoruz güvenli alanlar
arıyoruz bunları gerçekleştirirken de
taleplerimiz birbirinden farklı
olabiliyor Tabii ki
Örneğin Eskiden insanlar böyle
mağaralara daha güvenli yerlere işte
şimdi Savaş durumları var onlarla
alakalı olduğu için de
daha böyle Underground yerlere gitmek
istemişler buraları daha güvenli
bulmuşlar ama şimdi yüksek katlara doğru
çıkıyoruz hani benim artık Buralar benim
o hislerimizi kendimizle tatmin ediyoruz
bu his tatminleri ve bizim satın alma
alışkanlıklarımızı değiştiriyor
geçmişte evleri bağlarken
Bir de
geçmişteki teknolojilerde bir şekilde
evleri de birbirine bağladık Bu
yaşadığımız evlerde neleri birbirine
bağladık önce telefon çıktı bir kablo
çıktı evler birbirine bağlandı sonra
data transferleri ortaya çıktı internet
çıktı internette birbirlerine bağlandı
aslında burada evler birbirlerine
bağlanırken bir yandan da biz çevremize
bağlandık ailemize bağlandık
arkadaşlarımıza dostlarımıza bağlandık
ve bu ihtiyaç haline geldi daha sonra
cep telefonları çıktı artık mobil 4G
5g'lerden bahsediyoruz 5G teknolojisi
ile beraber bu transferlerde iyice hızlı
olmaya başladı ve birbirimize artık
istediğimiz mesajları ve bilgileri
gönderebiliyoruz aynı zamanda bizim
tarafımızda Teknoloji geliştirenlerde bu
bilgileri topluyorlar
nesnelerin
İnterneti ev içerisinde kullandığımız ya
da yaşam alanları içerisinde
kullandığımız ya da iş anlamında
kullanımları da var çok fazla örneği var
ama biz bugün bunun ev tarafında neler
oluyor onu anlatacağız büyük firmalar
cep telefonu bilgisayar Bu
teknolojilerle bir şekilde bizim
datalarımızı alıyorlar
bu aldıkları datalar
ürkütücü gelebilir işte ortam
dinlemelerini biliyorsunuz ona göre
reklamlar geliyor ekranlarınıza bir
anlamda bu pazarlama amaçlı kullanılıyor
bir taraftan insanlar
ürküyor ama tarih boyunca hep böyle
olmuş yani dün matbaaya şeytan icadı
diyenler Bu günde Bu teknolojilere karşı
çıkıyorlar insanlar hep bu anlamda üçe
bölünmüşler teknolojiye karşı çıkanlar
teknolojiyi kullananlar ve teknolojiyi
geliştirenler Ben üçüncü kesimdeyim ve
Önemli olan bu topluluğu biraz daha
büyütmek bakalım bugün sizi etkileyip
Bizim tarafa çekebilecek mi onlardan
bahsedeceğiz
bu nesneler birbirlerine bağlanırken
internet teknolojisi gelişirken bir
şeyler oldu Çok yakın zamanda
Öncelikle bilgisayarlar birbirlerine
bağlandı serverlar oldu bir yerde
bilgileri topladık sonra bunlar Claude
dönüştü artık serverlar da birbirlerine
bağlandı daha sonra blockchain oldu
Bunları artık kriptoladık birbirlerine
bağladık data transferleri bu şekilde
gerçekleşmeye başladı ama bunlar hala
teknoloji geliştiricileri için yeterli
değil
daha sonra Mark Zuckerberg çıktı ve dedi
ki yeni teknolojimiz metaboliz Neden
dedi bunu Çünkü çok mantıklı
ama insanlar bunu kabul etmedi
bahsettiğim mantık sadece markın
zihniyetindeki mantık öyle bir alan
hayal edin ki teknoloji geliştiricisi
tarafından hayal edin Empati kurarak
oradaki bütün datayı Analitik bir
şekilde alabiliyorsunuz yani Bu koltuğa
kaç kişi oturdu bu alandan kaç kişi
geçtiği bunların demografik yapıları
Bunlar kadın mı erkek mi Yaş aralıkları
neler ne tarz giyimden hoşlanıyorlar
üzerindeki avatarlar vesairler Her şey
sana da ortamda her şeyin datası var
bu çok önemli Çünkü teknoloji firmaları
bir yerde kitlendi artık sadece siz Eğer
cep telefonunuzu kullanıyorsanız
Bilgisayarınızı kullanıyorsanız biz
oradan data alabiliyoruz hangi web
sitesine gidiyorsunuz Neler yapıyorsunuz
Oradaki cookieler bir sene boyunca
kayıtlı kalıyor onları takip ediyoruz
vesaire
Hatta Çin'de bazı e-ticaret siteleri
artık kişiye göze göre ekranlar ana
sayfalar oluşmaya başladı Zaten
Türkiye'de de yaygınlıkla kullanılıyor
kişiye özel fiyatlamalar yapmaya başladı
Yani alacağımız Aynı ürün Sizin
ekranınızda farklı bir fiyat benim
Ekranımda farklı bir fiyat Bu da gelir
durumunuza göre kullanım
alışkanlıklarına göre değişebiliyor Bu
datalar bir yerlerde işleniyor
ama metal örsün temel bir problemi çıktı
ortaya
gözlüklerimizi takıyoruz ve çok sanal
yani geliştirici için çok heyecan verici
ama Kullanıcı için o kadar da heyecan
verici olmadı o yüzden şu anda kullanıcı
sayısı Gün geçtikçe azalıyor görüntüler
işte 1980'lerdeki Belki 1990'lardaki ilk
video oyunları gibi ileride birazcık
daha tarihi var ama benim konum
metaforce değil Meta virüsü nasıldır
reel hale getirebiliriz bambaşka bir
pencere açalım o sanal dünyanın
içerisinde almaya çalıştığımız dataları
nasıl
nesneler üzerinden alabiliriz Bu da ıoti
teknolojisi anlamına geliyor
nesnelerin interneti neden olmalı Çünkü
bunun iki tane temeli var Birincisi
kullanıcıya bizim bir katkı sağlamamız
gerekiyor Evinizdeki akıllı robot size
bir katkı sağlıyor Evinizdeki güvenlik
kamerası size bir katkı sağlıyor
güvenliğinizi sağlıyor ya da akıllı
çamaşır makineniz akıllı bulaşık
makineniz Bunlar internete bağlandığı
durumda size bir şekilde verilerinizi
Uzakta da olsanız evinizi kontrol
etmenizi sağlıyor Bu dataları bir
havuzda topluyor ve size anlamlı bir
şekilde getiriyor Hatta
sağlığınızla alakalı akıllı
baskülleriniz sağlığınızla alakalı
bilgiler de veriyor Bu ara çok kilo
aldınız yemenize dikkat etmeniz lazım
verilerinde size sunuyor bu kullanıcı
tarafında olması gereken şeyler
kullanıcı bir şekilde bu teknolojiden
fayda sağlamak zorunda
Peki teknoloji geliştirenler buradan ne
gibi fayda sağlıyorlar teknoloji
geliştirenler ise Siz cep telefonunuzu
Bilgisayarınızı kapattığınız anda dahi
evinizin içerisinde bizim sizin Ne
yaptığınızı bilmemiz lazım
biliyorum bunu bu kadar açık sözlülükle
söyleyen çok kimse yok ama gerçekten
bilmemiz lazım ki sizin hayatınızı daha
da kolaylaştırabilelim daha anlamlı
bütünler oluşturabilelim bu datalarla
birlikte
Ankara'daki insanlarla İstanbul'daki
insanların kullanım alışkanlıklarını ev
hayatı alışkanlıklarını ya da yeni
zelandaki bir kullanıcı ile Çin'deki bir
kullanıcının kullanım alışkanlıkları
farklılıklarını ya da yaş grupları
cinsiyet farklılıklarındaki farkları
bulabilelim ve buna göre ürün geliştirip
pazarlaması stratejileri
belirleyebilelim
hangi nesneleri internete bağlamamız
gerekiyor işte Az önce bahsettiğim gibi
sağlık konusuna geldiğiniz zaman
baskülünüz artık size bir Emay
değerlerinizi söylüyor kilo alıyor
musunuz veriyor musunuz bunları söylüyor
Hatta akıllı spor Ekipmanları ile
birlikte siz
bu alışkanlıklarınızı değiştirmeye
başlıyorsunuz bir Yapay Zeka ortaya
çıkıyor ya da kendi kendine öğrenebilen
bir sistem ortaya çıkıyor size ne
yapmanız gerektiğini bir şekilde artık
bilgisayarlar söylüyor enerji tasarrufu
sağlıyorsunuz şu anda dünyanın en büyük
problemi enerji ve akıllı şehir
sistemlerinde akıllı ev sistemlerinde
bir şekilde bu enerji tasarrufu
sağlanıyor yani sabah kalktınız
yatağınızdan
yatağınız sizin kalktığınızı biliyor
artık uyandınız perdeleriniz Güneşin
doğduğunu biliyor kahve makineniz
yatağınızdan almış olduğu veriyle sizin
artık uyandığınızı biliyor ve kahvenizi
hazırlıyor evden çıktığınızı
sensörleriniz biliyor ve evdeki
ışıklarınızı kapatıyor
bütün sistemi kapatabiliyor Belki eve
geldiğiniz zaman
temizliğiniz başlıyor ya da evden
çıktığınız zaman temizliğiniz başlıyor
beslenme alışkanlıklarınız değişiyor bir
akıllı sandalye düşünün oturma
alışkanlıklarınız değişiyor postür
bozukluklarını düzeltiyoruz akıllı masa
düşünün Ben bir boyun fıtığı mağduruyum
artık akıllı masanız kendine göre sizin
boyun mesafenize göre kendini
ayarlayabiliyor ya da diğer insanlar
nasıl kullanıyorlar Bunu onlara göre
size kullanım alışkanlıklarını öneriyor
aynı zamanda
önünüze koyduğunuz tabak kalori hesabı
yapıyor ve yediğiniz kalori hesabıyla
bizim arka planda eşleştirdiğimiz
baskülünüzden Almış olduğumuz veri ile
size sağlıklı yaşamın nasıl olması
gerektiğini Bir şekilde
şekillendiriyoruz bunu tek başınıza
yapmanız zor O yüzden bir şeye ihtiyaç
var
ayotti gelişimi
1-0 ile başladı ayotti 1-0'da Bizim
dediğimiz bir şekilde bir nesnenin
internete bağlı olup ondan alınan veri
üzerinden gerçekleşti Buna en temel
örnek CC TV kameraları vesaireleri
verebiliriz biz sadece datayı aldık
ayoty 2-0'a geldiğimiz zaman biz onları
artık uzaktan kontrol etmeye başladık
yani kameralarımızın yönünü çevirebildik
artık Akıllı Robotlar evimize geldi
Hatta ve hatta Medikal alanında
kullanımlarda uzaktan kontrol ettiğimiz
cihazlarla ameliyat yapabilir hale
geldik
Doktorlar Amerika'daki bir doktor
Türkiye'deki bir hastayı ameliyat
Edebilir hale geldi Bunların hepsi
teknolojinin eş gelişimiyle ortaya çıktı
Yani bugün 5G teknolojisine geçmiş
olmasaydık İnternetimiz yavaş olsaydı
ameliyatın ortasında robot kol takılıp
sıkıntılara yol açabilirdi
3-0 Hayal ediyoruz şu anda ayoty 3.0'a
geldiğimiz dönemde de artık o ameliyatı
yapacak doktora ihtiyacımız yok
artık o ameliyatı robot kendi kendine
öğrenmiş bir şekilde yapay zeka ile
yapabilir hale gelecek bu nesnelerin
Kendi kendilerine karar verebilmesi ve
kendi kendilerine çözüm üretebilmesi
yapay zekayı kullanabilmesi anlamına
geliyor artık yapmış olduğumuz otomasyon
sistemleri ile Uzaktan kumandayla Ya da
cep Telefonunuzda Evinizdeki ışığı açıp
kapatmayacaksınız Evinizdeki Işık sizin
ne istediğinize göre Hatta rengini
aydınlığını Ona göre ayarlayıp devam
edecek ışığı açıp kapatmak artık
birazcık geride kaldı o teknolojiler
şimdi yeni nesil yaratmaya çalıştığımız
dünyada biz bunları yapıyoruz Peki
bunlar nasıl gelişir hep birlikte
gelişir Az önce bahsettiğim gibi
teknolojiyi reddeden kesmeyi sol tarafa
bırakıyorum onlar orada kalsınlar
teknolojiyi kullanan insanlar bunların
faydalı olduğunu hayatına nasıl entegre
edeceğini bu dataları bu şirketlere
nasıl vereceğini hayal etmesi gerekiyor
bir diğer taraftan da benim burada çok
sayıda öğrenci var endüstriyel tasarım
yapan arkadaşlar da var az önce
görüştüğüm geleceğin evlerini
geliştirmek için bu arkadaşlara
ihtiyacımız var yani hayal ettiğiniz
burada Az önce bahsettiğim ürünlerden
bazıları gerçek Bazılarını ben uydurdum
şu anda olmayan ürünlerden bahsettik ya
da işte yeni bir şey hayal edelim
Evinizdeki şampuan
şişesinin akıllı Olduğunu hayal edin
bundan sonra
isterim ki bu toplantıyı dinleyen bu
konferans dinleyen herkes etrafındaki
eşyalara şöyle bir baksın Ben bunu
internete nasıl bağlarım Bu internete
bağlama işi de aslında hayal ettiğiniz
gibi çok kompleks bir şey değil Sadece 5
dolarlık 10 dolarlık sensörlerle bir
wifi modülüyle Bluetooth modülü olabilen
şeyler Önemli olan orada bir kullanım
amacı yaratmak bir 100 kez yaratmak onu
yarattıktan sonra geri kalan kısmı
pazarlaması stratejisi ve
satış Daha sonra da bu dataların
toplanması toplanan dataların ekosistem
içerisinde eritilmesi ve bu nesnelerin
hepsinin birbirleriyle konuşuyor olması
şu anda biraz böyle
ütopik geliyor olabilir ama bunların
hepsi zaten şu anda oluyor
olmaya da devam edecek
burada asıl önemli konu bu teknolojileri
geliştirirken
bir şekilde bir emek gerekiyor Ben bu
emeği sarf eden taraftayım
isterim ki ülke olarak bu emeği daha
fazla sarf edelim Çünkü bunlar yıkıcı
teknolojiler olarak nitelendirdiğimiz
artık bir şampuan Az önce şampuandan
bahsettiniz bahsettik şampuan firması
olmaya kalkarsanız çok büyükler var
orada rekabet edemezsiniz biraz realitik
olalım Yani bir startup dünyasında Bu
çok zor ama bir şampuan şişesi
yaparsanız akıllı bir şampuan şişesi
bunu
inanın bunu üreteceğiniz maliyet
prototipleme ve satışa gireceğiniz
maliyet Ankara'da herhangi bir bakkal
dükkanı açmaktan daha az bir maliyet
daha Ankara'daki Bir bakkal dükkanı
Muhtemelen 5 kilometre kare alandaki
insanlara hitap edecek ama böyle bir
ürün tasarlarsak bütün dünyaya hitap
ederiz Bütün dünya bizim ürünlerimizi
kullanıyor olur Bu anlamda
gençlerden olabildiğince ben de
mentörlük yapıyorum aynı zamanda
olabildiğince ilham vermeye çalışıyorum
olabildiğince onları bunlara
yönlendirmeye çalışıyorum ama taraf
sizin tarafı olmayan bertaraf olur
demişler umarım Bizim tarafımıza
gelirsiniz hoş geldiniz
[Müzik]